here we are I'm so excited to be joined
by some of the stars and filmmakers of
Marvel Studios black panther wakanda
forever
I love that sounds when a fantastic
question we're going to be talking all
about the new movie including a few
questions submitted by you the fans but
first please let me give you a warm
welcome and introductions to the half to
the folks joining us today so first of
all Mr director Ryan coogler Mr Producer
Nate Moore and what a front row we have
que Primera Fila Leticia right shurin in
the movie we have Nakia Lupita nyongo
which I know understands everything I'm
saying in Spanish and I love that and of
course which is namora the new character
in this movie foreign
for everyone to come watch this cast
November 11th the national boys
foreign
and I have to tell you guys I'm a huge
Marvel fans I love the MCU of course
this is a new movie I think it's great I
got the chance to see it yesterday and I
love it and what about we start with you
Ryan first of all I want to ask you of
course a Ryan Aiden and for everyone uh
the first one was a huge spectacle but I
don't know how you do it this one looks
bigger
actions is new characters
a lot of new locations so uh tell me how
was to return to wakanda but also bring
uh to this new movie the huge and lovely
city of talocan how was it was it was
fantastic
um
to have the opportunity to work with
these actors again to have a chance to
to deepen
uh our relationship with the characters
see new parts of wakanda and it was um
it was truly amazing to to uh be able to
bring talocon to the big screen uh
especially the characters named more
namora atuma
um it was it was fantastic for me and
um I think that I was not in the
minority of uh folks involved with the
film who aren't the best swimmers in the
world
um I had to have to commit to learning
how to swim so I could be there with the
actors and with the and with the the
camera team and the underwater stunt
team I think Nate kind of had it figured
out before
um but but uh it was it was it was it's
an amazing opportunity and I also to
learn more about the the cultures of
mesoamerica
um the pre-columbian history of
mesoamerica and
um to to make uh friends with with new
talented folks from different parts of
the world like my building and
technology and Alex uh it was truly it
was truly a fantastic opportunity and a
and a blessing
for you NATO West I was bringing uh yeah
it was really exciting I mean you know
when Ryan brought to us what he thought
the second movie could be if it was
impressive and daunting because whenever
you think about creating not only
revisiting wakanda but creating this new
world of talocon that is underwater you
realize there's a whole host of other
logistical questions you're gonna have
to answer and Ryan is such a grounded
filmmaker and wanted everything to feel
tactile and wanted performers to be in
the water to really move as if they were
in submerged environments which just
created a an interesting extra wrinkle
past making a movie of all these water
tanks and training people to be
comfortable uh performing in water but I
think all of that Fidelity shows up on
screen and so when you watch the movie
hopefully audiences are really immersed
in this world because the the actors and
actresses are really there who is
expecting that Lupita Latisha the brand
new world is coming to this movie
not at all
I mean when Ryan told me what the idea
was
I was kind of shocked and and and and
confused I mean when you read the script
you're just like well how are we gonna
make half this movie underwater you know
it just seems like a very impossible
task to do but then I remembered also
how much Ryan likes water because in in
the first film we had water a lot of
water we had water it keeps and then it
was water to our shins and then now we
just decided to do
entirely but I was also very excited to
to have that opportunity to learn how to
befriend the water how to grow
comfortable in the water because I think
that's a very important skill and one
that I think too often we overlook
indeed I I want to ask you my bill never
happened a
is
[Music]
an opportunities
foreign
oh my God I'm here in this team we did
amazing director and with this amazing
producer and they give me all the tools
for for me this story
real for me so I'm very grateful for
that yes
it's so great uh Ryan and Nate uh how
was to
or the approach to bring back uh wakanda
in the world of wakanda but at the same
time honoring the memory of Chadwick
Boseman and respecting his huge Legacy
yeah I mean uh I can say none of us
obviously expected to lose Chad
um and so
you know there's a version of this movie
where his character was a was a big part
of it but but once we all felt that loss
and were able to kind of process what it
meant
we had to figure out how to recenter the
movie in a way that both respected us as
artists and and didn't force us into
places we were uncomfortable with but
also gave audiences the opportunity to
revisit a world they loved you know I
think
I would go far to like Chad understood
what kind of meant to people so we had
to figure out how to revisit that place
but also Infuse into the storytelling
the very realized we were feeling the
loss that I think audiences were feeling
too
and so we tried to tell a story that was
honest to those emotions
um and that allowed the characters to
read the loss of t'challa in the same
way that we were grieving the loss of
the man and so give them the choice
the question became how do we best
tackle this again in a way that that
expanded the legacy of the man in the
world
um but allowed allowed us to deliver
something that we could believe
Leticia you worked so close that to him
in the first movie so that uh regard how
it was
coming back to this world
um
so yeah I the first conversation was
discussing with with my director how we
were gonna
we're gonna come together as a team to
honor my bro and
at first it was really it was really
weird for me because I was still
I was just really angry at the world I
was just really upset and I just didn't
I just didn't want to do it without him
and I just had to I just really had to
trust my my director I really had to
trust him as our leader as our brother
someone who's incredibly sensitive
um and instinctive as well he's really
instinctual about his choices he doesn't
just make it just to make it so I knew
when he was saying there's a there's a
light hair that we could tap into
that that changed my perspective and I
saw the opportunity to honor my brother
um in a way that I didn't before I I was
just angry and upset and I just turned
that around to how can I give the best
of myself and give the best of this
character that you know predominantly he
chose to be his this you know he chose
to be his sister
how can I how can I do my best in this
film alongside my team to to be
honorable to him and and that's how we
we tackled it together and I would say
that's the best way to play animash
working around it it's fantastic
it's so great let's chinch a little bit
uh of modern I want to talk about the
music
because this mix between the African
rhythms and these flutes from the
American cultures and the Mayan rhythms
so what can you tell me Ryan about what
do you want to do with the music in
wakanda Forever
yeah um uh you were able to work with
Google your son who's a composer on the
last film I had a long working
relationship with him and um
we try to work in a way that that's
that's organic and uh holistic
um we wanted to give audiences a
a unique experience
um and and we also wanted to to make
sure that since we were exploring
another culture and representing another
culture that we did the same type of
work that we that we did for the first
film
um and representing the cultures of
Africa through wakanda uh so Ludwig
immediately you know read the first job
for the script and booked time here in
in uh Mexico City uh and also in the
Yucatan region of the country uh worked
with um musicians I worked that were
from here in terms of making
contemporary songs but but also uh he
worked with musical archaeologists who
who kind of dedicated their lives to the
study of uh the types of music that
mesoamericans would would have would
have made art with
um during the the pre-columbian times
um and and that part of it I think was
was the most interesting because we
found um that a lot of the motifs of the
film were were present in in in in the
Sonic escapes of the people from that
time for instance
um seashells you know where we're a
massive part uh of how they made music
and it made a lot of sense obviously
because because telecon is is now in the
ocean in the MCU uh so that really
opened things up it blew my mind much
they sounded like french horns with the
with the humanity that we had in the
full of flutes that we use for
killmonger's theme in the first film
um so it was fantastic we also were able
to dig deeper into the music of the
continent you know um with both
contemporary sounds and also uh using
some of the the more traditional music I
mean it was a fantastic opportunity and
I think it's some of Louisville's best
work to be honest beautiful
very in the movie
I think those characters have inspired a
lot of of people around the globe so
first time was experiencing
that inspiration you provide with a with
the character and also the in any sense
you change the way you approach the
character for these new movies
it's very touching when people relate to
your character and cite your character
as a source of inspiration and you know
in the in the first film we had so many
female figures uh who are so different
from one another for for for
um to be Role Models or people you know
like there's a there's a good population
of women in this story that allow for
um young young girls young people to
identify with one or another kids say oh
I relate with your character Nakia for X
reason or I want to do stem thanks to to
shuri and
um it's lovely to be able to to be the
vessel for that kind of uh that kind of
inspiration
um and for this film of course I think
the death of Chadwick really changed the
direction that we were going with this
film
um and it um became part and parcel of
the evolution of the characters so in
this film uh you know Nakia has matured
she's lost her someone near and dear to
her and um she's navigating her grief in
a special way in a distinct way from say
how sure he is doing it and I think that
having those distinctions of how people
deal with grief in the first place is
also extremely helpful and healthy uh
because grief doesn't look the same on
everyone it's a it's a varied um it's a
it's a condition with lots of colors and
our film uh showcases or or explores
um grief in in a number of of different
and very helpful ways all these Leticia
changed the way you approach the
character
uh yeah for sure
um
in in connection to what the pizza just
shared and so beautifully
seeing so many young girls
be empowered by these by these women
um and not forcing it you know I mean
like we didn't do the film to to get a
particular result we just wanted to tell
the truth and I think when you do that
people receive it like better because
you're not trying to force it down and
throw it's just like we're just we're
just existing
um in in a in a in a world that is equal
and in a world that naturally you just
feel empowered when you look at these
characters on screen so that's the same
for this one
and yeah it is it is tricky because
we're looking at we're looking at the
ways in which
these beautiful women from the first
film are impacted by someone that they
love so much so yes it would cause you
to approach a character a little bit
differently
um but at the same time again just
staying on the path of telling the truth
and and that truth again can can Inspire
and and can also lead to to many people
feeling healed as well from from
touching into touching into the to the
ways in which the characters are dealing
with with this with this situation
um yes I mean
foreign
[Music]
and I gotta say Ryan and made as Mexican
to to see those references in the movie
so well respected
uh it's fantastic and it's and I'm
grateful for that but how hard was the
process to come to that conclusion of
what we're gonna be seeing in this uh
submersive City it's beautiful
uh I mean I think once Ryan had the idea
to sort of anchor the world of talocon
and Mesoamerican culture and really be
inspired both by ancient Mayan
civilization and present-day mind
civilization
then it's just the process of finding
the right Consultants who help us try to
get it as right as we can you know I
don't think any of us pretend to be
historians but but you do want if you're
going to pay homage to a place you do
want to get it right so we worked with
you know Dr Gerardo aldana who's an
academic out of the US who spent a lot
of time with the region we had an onset
interpreter for you you could take Mayan
dialect so that my bell and tenoch and
Alex always had a touchstone of someone
who is from the region who could speak
it correctly
um but I think trying to get those
details as right as possible
hopefully we'll build a world that
people feel as as cared for as wakanda
is because it's important when you're
when you're introducing again telecon as
Ryan referenced earlier you don't want
it to feel like we we didn't take the
time because it really is a love letter
to to both of these worlds and you
brought back Ruth and Carter that same
order of ideas so I
don't know I assume she was very
important
closure everything
absolutely absolutely um
Who's Back Hannah Bigler was back
um we worked with a great visual
development team that works on a Marvel
Studio supervised by Ryan Miner Dean and
I feel Sean is right
yeah like um so we we had we had all of
these incredible professionals who we
had relationships with we knew each
other's uh dispositions when it came
when it came to work and so it was
actually fantastic to get back to it and
I gotta say you know on yesterday I was
able to go to the museum it's like right
across from our hotel and um we went to
the to the Mayan exhibit with my family
and it was it was actually like
astonishing to see you know all of the
things that Dr aldana has shown us you
know pictures of and think some of the
things we kind of rebuilt to see the
actual things it was it was like it was
the most maybe one of the most surreal
experience I've ever had as a filmmaker
you know because we made this film
during during the pandemic it was not
you know easy to travel to the places
the same way that we did on the first
films we were you know I was traveling
digitally you know what I mean looking
at Google Google Earth and looking at
you know you know photographs we were 3D
printing things and it was to to walk in
there and see and see that actual
artifacts you know from what we study
see the the the the the the J workings
and the in the headdressers and uh all
of the texts you know um to actually see
it was was deeply moving you know if it
was deeply moving I felt like a um a
rich spiritual spiritual connection like
I felt like we did the right things you
know like we made the right Treasures
you never know you know it's like
um and and I think for me
the idea of Consulting works like the
industry of it you know the industry of
saying of not letting the fact that you
don't know be an excuse not to do it you
know what I mean like like going to find
the people who know paying them you know
what I mean and letting them letting
them inform what was happening like I
hope that we can
um be examples like a new type of
filmmaker at this level if that makes
sense before we go to the fans
questions and in regarding the fans and
everything what are you the most excited
about for the fans to sing wakanda
forever
me yep wow
that's me you're the man I mean
[Laughter]
it's a mini traditional um
what I would say what I would say it's
hard for me to pick one thing right you
know a lot winning it is
um a lot was sacrificed by everybody
individually collectively
um I've never been as proud of a movie
as this and I've been working for you
know over a third of my life you know
what I'm saying in this medium and um
when I when I watched the film I feel
the love that we have for each other uh
the love that we have for the medium
um the love that we have for our daily
departed friend uh and and I also feel
that
the wish to connect with people you know
what I mean like I I feel it like you
know and as we've been showing the film
to people I I think that part of it
works you know like like people people
will say hey this film reminds me of
when I lost this person that I loved and
or or or if this story reminds me when I
was going through this this this emotion
or when I was coming of age in this way
um so I'm actually looking forward to
audiences just having a good time at the
movies but also connecting with what we
were feeling at the time
um
amore
is
this is
foreign
[Music]
such an incredible character fans would
like to know what can they expect from
here
we can expect
a young woman going through the Journey
of Womanhood we can expect
to see Sherry in ways that we never
thought we would have before
um there's a maturity to her that's
really lovely I can speak to a lot of
young people who are probably on that
same path as well and we can expect
a lot of her Lively bubbly self but just
it's there's there's this there's real
real things that she's dealing with in
comparison to the first film and we see
the ways in which she handles that and
hopefully you can be of inspiration and
healing to others you can expect a lot
more stuff but you gotta you gotta see
it you gotta see it when it comes out
this weekend
see
Supreme
is
um foreign
[Music]
um
Ryan if I want to ask you about this
part of bringing the Spanish and the
Mayan will pronounce I was
that's very important for you why was it
very painful yeah language
is a big Motif in in
this these films this series of films
um this idea of uh of how that the
active Conquest historical conquest or
colonization can affect the way that
that people speak
um it was an idea that actually Nate in
in
um
I think discussed on Civil War like even
before
even before I was hired you know um and
like I can't express that the joy that I
felt when I watched Civil War for the
first time I was I saw a very early cut
we were trying to figure out if we were
going to work together and my mind was
blown when uh uh t'challa and tachaka
spoke to each other at the U.N in a
language it was a language I had never
heard before oh sorry South African
dialect and um and I I immediately
thought oh wow they invented a language
for the movie you know what I'm saying
it sounds awesome you know
and I talked to Nate after like a few
minutes after I watched the film he's
like oh no that's actually the language
that that the actor that we cast spoke
and I was like first of all it's one of
the most beautiful language I've ever
heard you know
um but second of all this is awesome you
know because the films that I loved when
I was young often gave up an additional
respect to language even when they
didn't have to I think about watching
the talking adaptations that Peter
Jackson did when their elves would speak
their own language you know um uh anyway
and you feel like the GL I think
geopolitan geopolitical films are best
when you you understand that people
communicate in ways that are entirely
different
um and especially these films we kind of
let colonization be a thing that we
wrestled with it became all the more
important
um it's very important in uh in the
Americas as it is on the continent you
know like you can learn a lot by people
about how they speak as we learn more
about Mayan culture and learn that that
you know it's uh
a large Mayan population still in this
in this place and they still speak the
language and something that they hold on
to with pride it made a lot of sense
um to make sure that the tower Canal
held on to that as well especially due
to uh landmark's character you know I
mean it felt like he was a person who
was trying to hold on to everything that
he could
um and uh you know so so we took it
serious man and
um it's like seven languages spoken in a
movie yeah
um we uh we had a lot a lot of fun with
that you know I'm a monolingual director
you know what I'm saying so it was it
was uh it was not without complications
you know uh not without unintentional
humor at times you know like
um we would have uh Josue
um who who was you know many times the
only person on set who spoke fluent mind
man he was working hard you know and we
we would bring him in and watch cuts of
the movie and he'll be like oh no you
got to fix this
right now they're saying something
that's not what you want him to say
um but but he had a deep
I I think as all Mayans do you know as
he was explaining to him he had a very
deep deep deep sense of um duty to make
sure we got this right yeah and then he
and he would not he would not he would
not uh hesitate to stress out upon us
and to stressed out upon our actors you
know what I'm saying it's very important
that you do this that you do this the
right way you know um and uh I was
honored you know um filled with a deep
sense of gratitude because I could not
imagine you understand being the only
person on the set having to represent my
whole culture you know amongst people
who were uh not as familiar with it as
as necessary
um and I hope we I hope we did
everybody's language and culture
suggestions you know what I'm saying yes
whenever this is
foreign
already hype up enough I think now there
are going to be even more excited to see
this movie and check uh all of your
incredible incredible work in wakanda
forever thank you all so much I hope you
enjoy your time in Mexico
and thank you all for watching we can
wait for everyone to experience the
movie get your tickets now for Marvel
Studios black panther wakanda forever in
theaters everywhere bye-bye gracias